- There is a chance that
COVID-19 was created in a lab.
And then it leaked out
and infected the world.
- [Lady News Reporter] Chinese city,
where the coronavirus pandemic
is believed to have started...
- A very competent,
trustworthy scientists.
- Probably it was incompetent.
Somebody was stupid.
- Whoa. Did I just say that?
Yes, I did.
Six months ago, I would not
have been able to say that
but today I can and we
need to talk about it.
Humans, including myself,
hate uncertainty, ambiguity.
We want to know what happened
but in the case of COVID-19,
we still don't know exactly what happened.
We don't know where it came from.
And to try to get at the real answer,
you have to navigate
all sorts of politics,
but wait, isn't this a science question?
Isn't it a matter of epidemiology?
The origin of a virus?
It should be but woven into
this scientific question
are a bunch of heavy political questions
and considerations that are influencing
what kind of questions
we're allowed to ask
and what kind of answers
we're allowed to give.
So, I wanna strip away the
politics, the tension with China,
the idea that this all sounds
like one big conspiracy
and I wanna just look at the
evidence of one question,
which is, where did COVID-19 come from?
- [Narrator] The most trafficked
wild animal in the world.
- Wuhan also has China's only bio-safety
level four super laboratory.
- China has a history of lab accidents.
(suspenseful music)
Are you suggesting that
maybe you have some evidence
that this was not a
naturally occurring virus?
- So it's not just me who wants
to know the answer to this.
Last month president Biden
asked the U.S intelligence community
to double down in answering
this one question,
where did COVID come from?
- It's important to
know the answer to that.
Right now, there are two major hypotheses,
one is the spillover hypothesis
and the second one is
the lab leak hypothesis,
which has up until recently
been seen as a fringe conspiracy theory.
- Complete baloney.
- And I'm gonna explain why
that changed in just a minute
but first let's look at each of these.
First, the spillover hypothesis.
- Health officials believe
COVID-19 originated in animals,
sold in a so-called wet market in China.
- Pangolin kissed the turtle.
(audience laughing)
- The spillover hypothesis says that
the coronavirus came from bats in China,
which is pretty predictable.
Bat's in China have tons of
corona viruses all the time.
They're usually not infectious to humans
but the hypothesis says
that a strain came about
that was infectious to maybe an animal,
maybe one of these guys, a pangolin.
And then that animal showed
up in some supply chain,
some market in central China
and it came in contact with the human
and the human got COVID-19.
And in fact, for a while, it
was this particular market
in Wu Han that was seen as the culprit.
They thought the bat
virus was in an animal
somewhere in this market.
And now listen for a really long time
up until just recently, I didn't
know this was a hypothesis,
I thought this was a fact.
In the early days of the pandemic,
they would talk about this
like it wasn't a question,
they'd be like, and the virus that came
from this meat market.
- The virus originated from a market.
- [Male Reporter] This meat market,
Ground Zero for the outbreak.
- But guess what? There's
no direct evidence for this.
They don't even have pangolin
in the Wu Han wet market.
And soon we learned that the
first official COVID case
had no contact with this market.
So the Chinese CDC had
to come out and say,
okay, no, it actually has
nothing to do with this market,
we have no idea where
this outbreak came from
but even after they said
that the market wasn't the epicenter,
the idea was still that
this came from a bat
that transferred it to an animal,
that transferred it to a human,
the spillover hypothesis.
The main reason why this
hypothesis gained so much traction
was because this is how
pandemics usually happen.
Of the past five pandemics,
four of them were the result of a virus
jumping from an animal onto humans.
So even though no one had
found an animal with COVID-19
to prove this theory,
they sort of presumed that it had to be
because look at these other four,
but wait, what about this one?
The Russian flu of 1977,
was likely the result of a lab accident.
And it ended up killing
hundreds of thousands of people
but even still the spillover
hypothesis was kind of gospel.
(suspenseful music)
Hey, real quick,
I'm gonna be doing a Q&A
on discord next week,
a week from today on Thursday,
it's gonna be a live stage event,
which is sort of like a personal like chat
with whoever wants to join.
Discord, by the way is the
sponsor of today's video.
Thank you Discord.
But anyway, this event
is where you can join
and ask me whatever questions you want.
And I will be talking for
an hour about storytelling
and about my process
and about the future of documentary things
and bright trip and all of the things
I will be answering all of your questions
in this sort of personal back and forth
Discord live stage setting.
Anyone can join, it's
free all you have to do
is sign up for Discord, which
is like a 15 second process.
Sign up for discord, there's
a link in my description
where you can register for this Q&A event,
which is next week, Thursday
at noon Eastern time.
Okay.
So I'm going to put on
the screen what time it is
in other time zones around the world,
noon Eastern time on Thursday,
I'll be answering tons
of questions on Discord
as a live stage event.
And I'm kind of excited
to hear from all of you,
to hear what questions you
have and to chat and catch up
and see what people are thinking about.
So, thank you this Discord
for sponsoring this video,
let's get back to it.
But quietly, there was another theory
that was brewing under the surface.
One that many experts
didn't talk about publicly
at the time, but they thought about.
They were thinking of
another building in Wuhan,
not this market, but another building
that was just a few miles down the road,
this one right here, the
Wuhan Institute Of Virology.
- So here's, what's crazy.
It's exactly in this lab in Wuhan,
where scientists have been experimenting
for years with corona viruses,
engineering them to make
them even more infectious
to human beings.
- More infectious to humans?
Wow! By the way, that's Podgy,
he's one of my producers.
He reached out to me a while back
and said that we should look
into the alternative hypothesis
of where COVID came from,
including this idea that it
may have leaked from this lab.
At the time I was quite skeptical,
I had heard rumblings about
the idea of the lab accident
that caused COVID and I'd
sort of written it off
because it just seemed so conspiracy
like just like low hanging for conspiracy,
like super engineered
virus escapes from lab
and starts global pandemic.
It's like new world orders.
It just reeks of internet
conspiracy and disinformation.
And in addition to that,
the only people who were touting this
were like people who are
not very good at the truth
and people who also liked
to pick fights with China.
- I can tell you that
there is a significant amount of evidence
that this came from that
laboratory in Wuhan.
- But I told Podgy that
if there's any evidence,
even circumstantial that
warrants looking further
into this hypothesis,
I would be interested
in checking it out.
And it turns out there was
such evidence and here it goes.
(lively music)
So, this is the lab leak hypothesis,
and I'm gonna unpack it the best I can.
First, let's talk about this lab.
It's located in central
China in the city of Wuhan
and for years, they
have been experimenting
on corona viruses what
Podgy was telling me about.
The question is, why
on earth would you want
to make a coronavirus
more infectious to humans?
- So this is what's known
as, gain of function research
and the idea is to study
more infectious versions
of the virus in order to
learn from that what we need
in order to stop the next pandemic
from ever happening in the first place.
- Gain of function research.
This is sort of like
testing nuclear weapons.
You're sort of playing with fire,
testing something that has the power
to kill millions of
people but you're doing so
in the name of like helping humanity.
There are only three places on earth
that do this sort of risky research
and it's supposed to be done
in these super high security
bio secure facilities that
have all these parameters
to make sure that the
engineered virus doesn't escape.
And by the way, in the
scientific community,
many people think this is
too risky and not worth it.
One critique I read from a
scientific journal said that,
"If the virus escapes, nobody
could predict the trajectory."
We're messing with
genetics and that's scary.
Okay, but just to remember for a second,
that all of this gain of function research
is happening in like 2015 through 2018.
Just rewind for a second.
None of us had heard the
word coronavirus before.
This was effectively some
boring, wonky, nerdy debate
happening between super niche scientists
who were studying the best
way to look at viruses
and all the while, as they did work,
studying all of these
corona viruses from bats,
the freezers in this lab
in Wuhan started filling up
with more and more samples of
corona viruses of all kinds.
Some just captured from bats and caves
and others engineered to be
more infectious to humans.
But again, no one really cared.
If I had made a video
about this work in 2017,
you wouldn't have watched it.
But in 2017, there was
someone who did care,
it was someone at the
U.S embassy in Beijing.
They caught wind that in this Wuhan lab,
they were curating corona viruses
and engineering more infectious ones.
This wasn't some secret,
this was like in
collaboration with scientists
in the U.S and around the world.
But even still, they sent
a team of health experts
to check out the lab and
what they saw troubled them.
The lab wasn't nearly as
safe as it needed to be.
And the managers at the lab said that
they were lobbying for more resources
so that they could hire
properly trained technicians
to safely run the lab.
The diplomats were concerned
and they sent two messages
back to Washington, DC
at two different periods of time.
They said this lab isn't safe
and the state department
should work with the Chinese
to tighten security.
These two cables went
back to Washington, DC
and both were ignored.
Again, this was like super
boring stuff in 2017 and 2018,
no one had heard of Anthony Fowchee,
this wasn't top priority.
So it was ignored, until 2020
when suddenly we all care about virology.
- Concerns about the deadly coronavirus,
officially getting the U.S.
(suspenseful music)
- Okay, so you have this lab
that's doing gain of function research,
there may be not very secure.
Now it's 2020, and I
need to explain something
that was hard for me
to understand at first
but it's very important.
Any hypothesis as to the origins of COVID
has to take into account
the fact that this new deadly
coronavirus called COVID-19
broke out in the very city
where the largest repository
of coronavirus samples
sit in a freezer in this lab,
some of which have been engineered
to become more infectious to humans.
Oh, in the lab has been
deemed not super safe.
If the outbreak had
happened in some other city
where there was no lab with a freezer
full of corona viruses,
we would not be having this conversation,
this would not even be on the table,
but Wuhan is the epicenter of
coronavirus samples on earth
because of this lab-
- Oh my God! There's been an outbreak
of chocolatey goodness,
near Hershey, Pennsylvania.
What do you think happened?
Like, oh, I don't know.
Maybe a steam shovel
mated with a cocoa bean
or it's the (beep) chocolate factory.
(audience laughs)
- Okay, wait, wait, hold on
I know some of you were thinking this,
I was thinking this,
at first, I thought this
was a logical fallacy.
Originally, I had said, well, of course,
it's not a coincidence that
there's a coronavirus lab
in the same city, that
there was an outbreak.
The lab was probably set up
because there's a lot of corona viruses
so they set up the lab to study it
so that they could prevent it
but then I read an interview
with one of the top researchers
at the Wuhan lab, one of
the biggest experts in bats
and corona viruses and
this changed my mind.
(upbeat music)
Her name is Shi Zhengli
but her nickname is, 'The bat woman.'
(crushing noises)
- You're about to become compost.
- Because she's made her
career out of going into caves,
getting coronavirus samples from bats,
so that she can study them.
She's like a top expert on this stuff
and she works in the Wuhan lab.
When she heard that there
was a coronavirus outbreak
in Wuhan, she was in
Shanghai at a conference,
so she got on a train
to rush back to Wuhan
so she's on this train and
later she said in an interview,
"I wondered if the local
health authorities got it wrong
by calling it the coronavirus."
She's like, something's off here.
Wuhan is in central China
and from the bat woman's
extensive study into this
she knows that it's
actually Southern China,
where all the bats are and
where coronavirus is most likely
to jump from animals to humans.
We're down here in Southern China
that's where COVID-19
cousin SARS broke out
in the early 2000, that's the place
where there is an actual
major risk of coronavirus
jumping from animals.
So the bat woman is on this
train, shaking her head,
she literally said in the interview,
"I had never expected this
kind of thing to happen
in Wuhan, in central China."
This is a thing that
happens in Southern China,
not Central China.
And then the terrifying
thought hit her, she said,
"Could they have come from our lab?"
Her first thought was the
health officials got this wrong,
it's either not coronavirus or if it is,
it probably came from our lab,
that's the more likely scenario,
not that it jumped from animals
like it does southern China.
So no, the lab isn't set up in Wuhan
because Wuhan is the
epicenter of corona viruses
jumping from animals,
instead Wuhan's relationship
to corona viruses isn't that it's common,
that it breaks out in wet markets,
no, it's because of the lab.
The lab is the world's largest sample
of corona viruses on earth.
Now, let's be clear this isn't part proof
that anything happened,
this is circumstantial
but it is absolutely a firm
foundation for a hypothesis
that potentially this
could have come from a lab
bat woman herself, that
was her first thought.
And as I've been reading the
accounts from other virologists
and epidemiologists around the world
who heard of a virus coming out of Wuhan,
they thought about the lab.
They're like, oh, shit
there's a giant lab there
with tons of viruses, I
wonder if it came from there.
Now, listen, this lady who
we're calling, bat woman,
the bat expert, went to the
lab as soon as she got to Wuhan
she was sort of freaking out.
She had been losing sleep.
And she looked at all of
the data, all of the samples
and determined that none
of the samples engineered
or natural were the same as COVID-19.
None of them were an exact match
and she sighed a breath of relief
and she felt like,
okay, it wasn't our lab.
For most scientists, that was enough proof
to put the lab leak hypothesis to rest.
They're like, oh yeah,
bat woman said that,
none of the samples were
identical to COVID-19
but for many others,
trusting this one woman
to tell us the truth
or to have done a thorough investigation
is not good enough evidence
for us to rule this out.
The world who has suffered
greatly because of COVID-19,
deserves a chance to truly investigate
not trust one Chinese researcher.
- The world has reached
another grim milestone
in the history of the
coronavirus pandemic.
- This is globally the
death toll has now topped
a staggering 3 million people.
- But for some reason,
China is not really playing
ball with letting an inquiry
or an investigation happen.
When Australia got up
and called for a transparent investigation
into COVID origins,
including looking into
the lab leak hypothesis,
China immediately retaliated
with economic sanctions
on Australian products like wine and beef.
What?
A little defensive.
Like wouldn't China want to have
an independent investigation
into this hypothesis
so that if it's false,
it can be proven false
and we can put it to rest.
It seems like that would
be in their interest
and yet they're making
it incredibly difficult
for anyone to do an investigation.
Instead, we have to rely
on U.S spies and intel
to like piece this together.
The Wall Street Journal recently reported
that there was intel that said that,
three researchers at
the Wuhan lab got sick
with COVID like symptoms
and they had to be
hospitalized in November 2019,
weeks before the first
official case of COVID.
Again, this isn't proof
but it's definitely reason
to ask more questions.
China, stop making us
rely on intel from spies,
put the hypothesis to bed
and let us investigate
but they won't, which is
like incredibly suspicious.
- Mike at the end of the day,
it's profoundly in China's
interest to do this as well
because look, it's suffered too.
- That's the lab leak
hypothesis, unsafe lab,
that's the coronavirus epicenter
and an engineer's viruses to
be more infectious for humans
has a little mishap, which
turns into a global pandemic.
It's a feasible hypothesis
that deserves investigation.
Now, listen, if your brain
is anything like my brain,
what both of our brains
are doing right now,
is scheming to find
some sort of certainty,
we're like, oh, look at
all this evidence here.
They were in the hospital
and Wuhan is actually the epicenter
and we're like piecing it all together.
Our brains love to do this,
to lay out the circumstances
and fill in the blanks
so that we can believe in
some sort of certain thing,
our brains hate ambiguity
but please don't be tricked
by your hate for ambiguity.
We have to remember that
neither the spillover hypothesis
nor the lab leak hypothesis
have solid direct evidence
that proved them one way or the other.
The main evidence for the
spillover hypothesis right now
is the idea that historically,
this is how viruses like to start,
they jump from animals onto humans.
That's a really solid
basis for our hypothesis.
We should absolutely
continue to investigate that.
But guess what?
It's been a year and a half
and we haven't found an animal
who carries COVID after a year and a half?
So as of now, it is still in
the category of hypothesis
but if you read the news in 2020,
it seemed like the case was
closed, it was a settled thing,
yeah, the coronavirus
jumped from an animal.
- The pangolin.
- Pangolin.
- Pangolins.
- Probably one of these
pangolins in a market,
everyone move on.
Meanwhile, the lab leak
hypothesis also had solid basis.
None of the evidence I've
talked about today is new,
it's all been around.
And yet until recently
the idea of a lab accident
being the origins of COVID-19,
was deemed as far off fringe conspiracy.
- This question about the Wuhan lab,
we know that it's been debunked
that this virus was manmade or modified.
- A major reason for that
was because there was
the Trump administration
that was constantly
overstating the hypothesis,
claiming they had way more
evidence than they actually did,
labeling it, the China virus.
- The Chinese virus.
It's not racist at all, no, not
at all, it comes from China.
- Which helped fuel a
spike in discrimination
and violence against people
of East Asian descent.
And then Tom Cotton
gets up and says, this-
- The virus went into that food market
before it came out of that food market.
So we don't know where it originated
but we do know that we have
to get to the bottom of that.
We also know that just a few miles away
from that food market is China's only
bio-safety level four super laboratory
that researches human infectious diseases.
- Well, this is awkward.
Yeah.
It turns out what Tom Cotton said,
actually is totally sensible.
I had written this into the script,
thinking that Tom Cotton
said some crazy stuff about something.
- What 5G actually does, it absorbs oxygen
and that's really important know.
- But it turns out that Tom Cotton
back in like February of
2020 was stating a hypothesis
that a bunch of scientists
now think is totally legit.
Nothing's changed, we
don't have any new evidence
and yet at the time it was written off
as a total fringe conspiracy.
Here's the New York Times,
Senator Tom Cotton repeats fringe theory
on coronavirus origins.
It was completely downplayed, written off
and put aside as a fringe conspiracy.
This was a failure of journalism
and journalism's job of
looking into hypothesis
and actually validating them
based on the available evidence
as Tom cotton says, "There actually wasn't
any direct evidence
and there still isn't."
And yet today nothing has changed
but scientists look at the hypothesis
and see it as totally legit
and worthy of investigating.
And I almost just got
caught in the pitfall,
trying to do journalism
and about to regurgitate
what I read on the Washington
Post and New York Times
that Tom Cotton said some crazy stuff,
when he actually didn't.
That is dangerous, when
reporters just repeat
what others are and jump on the bandwagon
because it's correct to do that.
What's correct is to go report
and look into the evidence,
which is something that a
lot of journalists didn't do
during this time.
And so scientists, even if they believe
that we should investigate it
and the media downplayed it,
wouldn't touch it until recently.
- Now the coronavirus may have leaked
from a lab in Wuhan China.
- [Lady News Reporter]
U.S president Joe Biden
launched the investigation in late May.
- Why would you have a bad
coronavirus outbreak in Wuhan
and not in Southern China
where these horseshoe bats are located?
- Trump left office
and things settled down
with China a little bit.
And lo and behold, we're
now seeing legitimate,
well-respected experts on
this topic come out publicly
and declare that the lab leak
hypothesis isn't a conspiracy
and that both hypotheses
need to be taken seriously
until we have sufficient data.
It's called science, by the
way, it's just called science,
should look into legitimate hypothesis.
But what was troubling
to me is that even still,
there are scientists who
are digging in their heels
saying that the case is closed.
- There is zero evidence that this virus
came out of the lab in China.
- Like this guy, for example,
he's a leading expert in animal
diseases and disease ecology
and he's been the leader of
calling the lab leak hypothesis,
a fringe conspiracy theory,
like since the beginning,
when we knew nothing,
but here's the thing,
this guy has skin in the game.
His NGO gets loads of funding
to perform research at,
wait for it, the Wuhan lab.
- [Male Reporter] Members
of the scientific community
have said that Daszak has
a conflict of interest
due to his close ties to the
Wuhan Institute of Virology
and its leading scientist, Shi Zhengli.
- Yes of course, he
doesn't want the Wuhan lab
or gain of function
research to be smeared,
like this is his home
turf where his livelihood
and his life's work comes from.
And he's the guy we're listening to?
Like we're letting this
guy lead out on the inquiry
about where the origins
of COVID come from?
(suspenseful music)
Oh and it gets worse.
So the WHO, World Health Organization
sent a group to investigate
the origins of COVID
a few months ago and this
guy helped lead the team.
I mean, he's like a world
expert, but guess what?
The results of what he came
back with, were not surprising.
- A team Of international experts
investigating the origins of COVID-19
have all but dismissed a theory
that the virus came from a lab.
- And talk to people,
ask critical questions,
got critical answers and
they've come to their conclusion
and I have as well and what
they say is extremely unlikely.
- But then eventually a
journalist calls him out.
- Given that this report
rules out of that leak,
isn't your credibility on
that a little undermined
by the fact that you've been saying that
even before you came here?
- No.
- Yes, you can't go into an investigation
with your mind already made up dude!
Especially when millions
of dollars of funding
for your organization is on the line,
that's not science that's
self-interest and tribalism.
Listen, I don't doubt that Daszak
is an earnest believer in his theory,
I mean, he's a zoologist by training
of course he thinks it jumped from animals
but this shouldn't be the
guy doing the investigation.
Oh, and it's not just me who
thinks that this investigation
was BS, the head of the
WHO, literally the head
who commissioned this study said that
the investigation into
the lab leak theory,
"wasn't extensive enough."
It was too hasty.
So yeah, they didn't
actually look into it.
This scientists are not
actually looking earnestly
for empirical evidence.
Okay, that was a lot. there's
a lot to soak in here.
And I wanna give you a few big takeaways
that are like nothing we should
take away from this video.
Number one is that, we don't know,
I know we all hate to hear
this, but we don't know.
The evidence I've laid out here
for both the lab leak hypothesis,
as well as the spillover
hypothesis is all circumstantial
meaning, it's like you have
to connect a lot of dots
to make it work.
And science isn't about connecting dots,
it's about proving something
with solid evidence.
We don't have solid proof of anything.
So please, please, please
don't give into the temptation
to now believe that COVID came from a lab.
It may have come from a lab
but it may have jumped from animals
after being infected from
bats, we do not know,
we should investigate both.
Number two, it is mind blowing to me
that a hypothesis can be labeled as fringe
and conspiracy all because of politics.
And then it can just
immediately get reversed
depending on the political climate.
The media so hardcore
downplayed the hypothesis
of the lab leak and they did
so because Trump was in office
and he was using an
overstated version of that
to stoke hate and tension and lies.
So I kind of get it but we
sort of threw the baby out
with the bath water.
Number three, it is
very disappointing to me
that scientists whose
motives should be nothing
but seeking the truth, keeping
everything on the table
that has any promise, they
are digging in their heels,
throwing a legitimate
hypothesis off the table
and lobbying to keep it out of the public
and showing that they're
probably influenced
by the fact that their funding
and life's work is associated
with the other hypothesis
that they don't like.
I get it when politicians do that
but leading experts who were
all looking to for truth
and guidance, like, come on guys,
we need to stay open to any hypothesis
that has a reasonable basis to stand on
and we need to do that so we can find out
how this thing started
and ensure that it never happens again.
- A final note, more than a year ago,
top scientists published a letter
in the prestigious medical journal, Lancet
that dismissed the lab leak theory,
they called a conspiracy theory.
So ABC news reached out
to all 27 scientists
who signed that letter
about a dozen responded,
several of them telling us,
they're not so sure this
thing came from nature
and one scientist is telling
us he's flipped entirely
and he believes it now the lab
leak theory is more likely.
(beat box music)